neun leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer hunger games runde auf den sehr
cool punkt.de minecraft server ich bin
hier auf einer user map alle
schreibenden städters die mich kennen
und befolgte schreiben dass ich der
falsche pin und ein fake ok dann bin ich
ein fähiger irgendwie ist mein kind
nicht sichtbaren kay bis dahin mein gebt
mir schreiben die gastwirte bist du der
echte das ist ein premium server und
frage mich ob ich das bin ja ich hab
gedacht ich immer wieder eine runde
hunger games auf der euch dass ihr alle
gewünscht habt wie immer wenn ihr
wünsche habt sie irgendwelchen sachen
die ich aufnehmen soll dann schreibt das
bitte einfach unten in die kommentare
und ja also ich hab die met noch nie
gespielt ich sehe dass gerade zum ersten
mal
ich kann einfach ein chat fragen wann
geht es los mit einem smiley immer wenn
ich habe sogar youtuber von jetzt hey
guck mal das tupac oder so ich weiß
nicht ich dahin laufen oder in die mitte
sind darum endlich auch kisten jutta
sonneck ist ich weiß ich erst mal hoch
laufen
ich glaube ich versuche erst mal als
erstes die
ortete mich rein ich versuche erst mal
direkt da oben hoch zu laufen mit die
kiste glauben zu krallen weil
wahrscheinlich alle hier unten hin
laufen werden
ich weiß zwar nicht genug ich weiß ja
nicht ob das was bringen wird aber naja
wartet das so boten stimmt / sgv
gamestar den 20 ok wenn leute das gros
der online scanner hallo fahne von 17 6
5 4 3 2 1
ok schnell weg
so eine komische dass das model changing
jetzt habe ich einen alben halbes level
war voll geil so gegend liegt sieht das
hier nicht noch eine andere games aus
sondern einfach nur noch normalen web wo
immer dran gebaut wurde
meine was ist der sinn davon so ich weiß
nicht vielleicht werde ich noch eine
zweite runde
packen wir denke ich sogar sehr
wahrscheinlich wohl häufig gar
eigentlich hin
denn gerade in einer höhle drin aber
mein gott fest
wtf ist das bitte für eine app die hat
ja nicht mal irgend eine kiste hier
unten
ok moment habe ich die helligkeit ich
hab so aufbereiten dass er trotzdem zu
dunkel
naja ich frag mich allgemeine mal also
die asian games map von von relativ geil
das hier ist eine mühsame weise wurden
von ihm erstellt und wir hier sieht's
aus berlin was wäre toll jetzt ist ihr
laden ja toll was ist das bitte für den
map ist janina irgendwas oder hinten ist
ein name der verstecke ich will lieber
jetzt habe ich auch so in der höhle hier
drin
ich komme ich dann endlich wieder hier
hoffe ich kann nix abbauen
dass das ist ziemlich laut
ich meine meine lieben freunde was
bringt eine map wenn ich jetzt hier drin
feststecken nicht hochkommen erklärt mir
das bitte hallo hätte genau wieder
rauskommen oder so das wäre ich der
bandit von euch
hier vielleicht wird ja ganz einfach
drauf kommt dann gehe ich dann nicht
offen wieso jetzt bin ich hier
okay ich bin auf dem weg wieder nach
draußen verlegen die kiste oder so weil
ja okay ich hab hier noch nie hat sich
wehgetan
hier sieht sehr sehr groß aus wir müssen
doch mal gegen die kisten sein
das hkz über alle nix keine einzige
kiste super mega ich hoffe mal wieder
hoch und versuchen die ans tageslicht zu
kommen weil das ist echt schön die
abiturienten gerade wo ging es nochmal
ansehen aber auch kein essen mehr
okay die runde wird nicht so geil sein
ist hier jemand ist das hier bob quick
da draußen
nein es ist eine sackgasse je freuen wir
uns doch alle ganz toll
sowohl wo kann ich denn hier sonst lange
habe ich eigentlich schon schaden
genommen
also da ging es runter hier her bin ich
gekommen
hierher doch aber da oben annahmen das
ist doch schon mal ganz gut wenn
annahmen sind es immer gut okay hier ist
ja die chance von vorhin hier bin ich
auch froh dass ich irgendwie hoch
gekommen bin
leute ich krieche gleich irgendwie einen
rappel wenn ich unten bleibe sehr derbe
dunkel war hier geht's lang lkw
tageslicht ich meine was bringt sonne
ok
jemand wollte war ich muss doch
irgendwie und jetzt
derzeit verpackt oder wie jetzt komm ich
nicht hoch
hey was bitte ergibt das für einen sinn
ich bin jetzt hier und ich komme hier
nicht raus und dem sterben
komme aus der höhle nicht raus was
ergibt das für einen sinn
hier waren nicht mal kisten
ach ich an appellen cool ich weiß nicht
warum und jetzt kann mich heraus pforten
oder unten wenn er kommt ich bin ich
raus der luft weg
das ist eigentlich so das was ich
überhaupt nicht will in hunger games ja
toll schön gemacht danke sehr nett aber
irgendwie ergibt das für mich keinen
sinn so tschüss du darfst mich gerne
umbringen wenn du willst weil das es
sinn des spiels
sonst gehe ich jetzt noch mal in die
länge ich total home oder server ich
eigentlich eher weniger da oben ist eine
person
wisst ihr was nicht dass dich umbringen
weil es ist eine sehr sehr langweilige
runde gerade
hallo du da jetzt bring dich um
das bring ich um kranke so dann gehen
wir nun auf einen anderen server weil
die attacke an
so können wir denn hin
da den servicefall knapp 500
da sorgt ok
fahrt mal welche 414 sie schon volles
brett schreiben
so wollen wir in den raum da
rheinenergie sträußchen oder wollen wir
weg laufen
ein flugzeug dann geht es bestimmt
irgendwie hoch bild oliver braun laufen
man kann er im backofen
nur ganz am rande von kraft an ein ich
mache ich mit euch team
wenn ich dann mal los
welche folge sonst finde ich neuem stück
weg ich meine flaschen moment
so
sgv thalia moment ich bin am trinken
kann wieso weiß ich dass ihr betrieb
mensch ähnlich sg lautet es dort zu game
allein 16 worten habe ich doch schon
schreibst die anderen so close games
torlinie toni cool superman hat das ist
irgendwie so ein toller typ
fcw danke kong kräfte johanning so 21
ich hab mein schwert gott sei dank kommt
jetzt wieder raus
nachdem wir alles relativ dollar naja
ich kontrolliere dass sie erst mal noch
mal bin auf jeden fall schon mal ganz
gut ausgerüstet werde ich erst mal
umbringen wenn ich ihnen gleich kriege
ich glaube das ist eine coole runde
cooler schmeißen links und sein
komisches talent beim eigentlich gerade
wieder blöd das ist eine ganz kleine mit
ihr
naja ich werde mal alles um bringen was
ich ihr in die quere kommt hier
eigentlich vorbei so du bist jetzt
erstes dran glauben mein lieber freund
john places klar bei dir du guckst man
den kisten darauf dass drin ist nicht
klar da was dran nee auch nicht da war
schon vorbei fick dich da stadt
nirgendwo im chat raceboard vorbei ist
für unfair ist das denn
man habe ich natürlich total hingerissen
der tolle sind blöd von mir weil oder
blöd vom chat oder bitte periode man
fakt jedoch weg die leute auf dem
circuit von crafter so dastand niveau
das die grace period vorbei ist wenn ich
jetzt hier und das nervt da stand
nirgends war dass die krise vorbei ist
deswegen ich verstehen uns nicht und
sagt man steht das thema wenn die grace
period vorbei ist naja und lieben
freunde danke fürs zuschauen wie immer
würde ich mich über eine positive
bewertung freuen uns euch gefallen hat
wenn ich dann darum runter und ihr könnt
mir einfach mal ideen in die kommentare
schreiben
irgendwelche adventure maps oder
irgendwas let's play artiges gegen dem
motto oder irgendwie sowas keine ahnung
hätte ich mal wieder bock drauf also
selbst beim nächsten mal noch einen
wunderschönen tag und tschüss